вступна кампанія вища навчальна
заклад починається сьогоднішнього дня
більше вони розповість наш кореспондент
її називаю rain очка доброго ранку скажи
будь ласка, що вдалося дізнатися
клею літаючі раз і ясна сьогодні
пітерленд і може подавати документи
до вступу до вищих початкових заходів
здатні вести тягу річкову ланцюгову
компанією ця ще
абітурієнти за програму та бакалавра
можете подавати документи в електронному
у вигляди а вас на ваших екранах ви
можете побачите за 1 сайт на кому 3 бари
з трубок та документи і вас намалювати
їх в електронному виглядає менше прав
setzer usb це йому заступника директора
департаментів ще свити міністерство
світлі науки на григорія ми отримаємо
доброго ранку
ранку так 10 на сьогодні розхиталася
вступ на компанія активна фаза та
абітурієнти може подавати документи до
електронному виглядати на вигляд по
видному сайті
відразу мило мета дозвольте розван теж ти
при маленькій місії зменшить і черв'як
етапі їх практично не повинно бути
абітурієнт може подавати документ і
адже виходять з дому видно
це може бути 15 заявок на 5
спеціальностей завертай уго відчув уроку
ми бачиш вигляд позиції ближче нікель
кістки
вищий навчальний заклад його за вийшов
вище 5 спеціальності колиму ладу люди
напали на ви значите столітті самій
спеціальності та cyka [ __ ] іпатова ти
мажеш гусей вузи в думках 15 заяву
важливим десь ще як що в абітурієнтів і
якась проблема skoda ним в електронному
виглядай документі ви нам уже в день
може згорнути адабу декору на еблищі
чого ви з чого початкового закладу та
прямо льону комісія чогось початкового
закладу
так допоможе йому у форми ти ж поведінка
документи та подати їх в електронному
виглядає ще забезпечити можна звістку
Швидко ефективно заповнив від ці форми
ці представлені на сайті я до вас за
інформацію колу та друзі я дам зара tube
на компанія компанія трава тема
dakine seal та пня pussy more нового дня
абітурієнтам обожнюються успіхи